le bronze disposer aujourd'hui on se
trouve sur you l'hiver sandbox un jour
notre terrain de jeu c'est l'univers
tout entier au quai joffre basique tuto
donc là on fait donc on à l'univers
qu'elle a avec toto planète ici on à
mars on a aussi jupiter on a des petites
bon bref on a le système solaire est ici
c'est la fenêtre des simulations ça veut
dire qu'on peut cliquer à un endroit et
sera chargé une simulation qu'on va
pouvoir voir c'est trop beau jean
lassalle à une situation de deux
satellites au une simulation de
collisions de galaxies mon gars non ça
ça va être incroyable ça chaque seconde
regardez combien d'années c'est cool
c'est titanesque c'est super beau et
s'ils accélèrent elles vont se rentrer
dedans ça regarde elle s'inspire l'une
et l'autre c'est des millions d'années
qu'on voit en quelques secondes c'est
abusé aux hell's ass quel espace qu à la
fin de l'été le pub saunier où il ya
plein de fumée partout mais dans
l'espace en version naturelle
ça donne une grosse galaxie finalement
c'est trop beau a tant à faire toutes
les simulations obligé jupiter qui
volent autour du soleil à temps mais ça
va faire exploser le soleil ça non mais
c'est pas du tout j'ai pu dire qu'ils
volent autour du soleil c'est la fin de
deux heures s'est plaint petit jupiter
qui volent autour du soleil et vous pc
qui rend d'abord c'est tellement joli
mais la vidéo la vidéo savais que ça
c'est juste moi qui regarde quelque
chose qu'il fait c'est bobby baril
pulsar qu'est ce que c'est ou là ou pas
dans un délire un peu chelou games et la
soupe aux choux des luttes qui se
rentrent dedans attendait de voir ça au
chaud aussi super bon et du coup ça
devient tout confusion de la mort qui
tue quoi à temps mais c'est le plus beau
jeu du monde
le bombardement de la lune qu'est ce qui
se passe c'est patrick voyer sur la
lutte c'est ça boume wyeth à l allure
elle se prend des claques à redon la
mettre dans la vraie vie elle se prend
des astéroïdes haute et deux passes pour
à la hausse et saturn avec son ado ouah
ça va peut être préféré saturn parce
qu'avec son anneau elle est tellement
particulière elle et lui dit qu'elle a
voulu se donner un style différent des
autres et pour ça je la respecte vous
voyez elle n'a pas voulu se fondre dans
la masse des planètes c'est super beau
[ __ ] nommé c'est incroyable nater avec
plein de lune
huawei avec des collisions à temps
j'espère que la terre elle va rien se
prendre un ainsi si la terre le vent
arrive mais imaginez s'il se passait ça
dans la vraie vie si avait plein de
planète comme autant de l'uba autour de
nous et que toutes les luttes se rentrer
dedans ce qui se passerait pour 12 quoi
on est vraiment des petits kaka sur
cette planète là tout ce qui se passe
autour là c'est tellement géant stand
titanesque côté doux pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'apprend pas les sciences de
l'espace avec ça au collège et au lycée
c'est bizarre c'est tellement
intéressante est loin captivant où tu as
envie du tout fouillé partout la terre à
côté du soleil en lui la fin test de
climat d'accord de garder des gens qui
font des tests récente ific 2603 degré
il ferait sur terre si on était si près
du soleil vous rendez compte mehdi star
zéro salaires trop bas ou la potée
sirius un pas confondre avec cyprien
voilà je tenterais d'inde de l'espace et
dans les pages de faire de l'espace et
du potager robin fait j'ai pris de faire
des blagues en fait j'ai vraiment envie
juste d'admirer la beauté de ce jeu
regardez comme c'est beau vous savez
l'espèce de leggings et les choses sur
galaxy la banda ils sont inspirés
directement comme ça lucas et moi ça
please say pour une envie de caresser la
terre contre des astéroïdes alors
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si je veux
voir où ça arrive de la gauche aux
danses à faire trop mal boga latéral va
péter déjà les astéroïdes par rapport à
la terre et son kop énorme un mythe de
rennes seront pas contents il faut
treize kilomètres par seconde et ils
font 119 kilomètres de diabète ou de
rayon chez pas déjà cela fera près par
les us bizarrement
au revoir barack obama au revoir les
états unis c'est la fin pour vous nous
on est là on est juste là pour le moment
on va bien comment la france va bien la
france la france est morte c'est fini on
s'est pris un peu d'esprit tu arrives
pas ça va pour nous ici par un vrai
changement c'est qu'avec les ondes de
choc et les répercussions qui a je pense
qu'on est tous morts alors eux ils sont
morts b d'une violence au dire que ces
lumières la bête des millions d'années
atteint de petite terre
c'est fou aujourd'hui on est en mode
science et vie voilà je suis un cours
d'svt c'est gratuit raconte à la fin
vous aurez des devoirs bah ouais bah
ouais je suis désolé vous allez devoir
bas pour demain vous l'aï créé cette
vidéo c'est drôle ça au salut moi
j'adore voir comme une planète prend des
chocs parce que j'espère que ça arrivera
jamais en vrai bond à la chance de bien
voir will l'impact que ça aurait c'est
abusé oh là là regardez voici en
présence et les autres de choc en fait
l'hôte de choc fait la moitié de la
planète quoi bombardement du soleil art
qu'est ce qui se passe
oui ça fait oui d'accord oui ça fait que
d'alcoa le soleil totalement invincible
s'emballer steak regarder le soleil s'en
fout qu'est ce qui se passe yolo chaud
soleil m'engage nourrit tout le monde
que tu vas faire à quoi que s'il prend
tarif quand même ça fait des gros éclat
asi soleil explose à jour ce qui est je
crois prévu mais on est pas dans la
merde t'as va brûler tout ce qui existe
ça donne carrément envie de voir s'il ya
de la vie ailleurs parce qu'en fait nous
re des on est vraiment des gens sur une
petite planète comme ça vous voyez on
est des petits kaka et y'a pleins pleins
d'autres planètes se souvient totalement
de la vie ailleurs
et avec d'autres galaxies de trucs comme
ça qui regroupe en a pas de planète
ah là là c'est beau la vie aux deux en
mode squeeze début aujourd'hui le
système solaire avec toutes les planètes
et toutes les lunes vous rendez compte
c'est obligé qu'il ya de la vie ailleurs
c'est sûr quelque part même très très
très loin ou plus loin des galaxies ses
dunks on arrive quand même à savoir
qu'il ya ça là ça là bas et c'est alors
qu'on nous on est là comme on arrive à
voir des trucs qui sont aussi loin c'est
impressionnant ça c'est ce qu'on voit à
priori mais qu'est ce qui nous empêche
de croire qu'il ya pas exactement la
même chose ici par exemple voyez à la la
c'est tellement intéressant tout ça ça
donne envie de regarder les eaux
conférence d'alexandre astier
voilà on va se cultiver un peu haussé
pause ça qu'est ce que c'est moi parce
que c'est beau avec cette musique soit
le connais je suis tout ému
j'étais fatigué aujourd'hui j'avais pas
trop envie de rire à fond et c'est
vraiment le jeu parfait quoi je suis
très content c'est super bon bah merci
et je sais plus qui me l'a conseillé
mais c'est une oeuvre d'art ce jeu sont
déconnectés vis avec la musique
c'est beau c'est tellement jolie c'est
pas ça se trouve vous n'avez pas la même
sensibilité quoi êtes-vous fait
totalement chier mais je trouve ça
tellement joli mois on a pris tu arrives
par contre la terre est maintenant à
2600 degré 700-800 ya un problème
même obama s'il veut survivre je sais
pas comment il ferait là il partirait
comme ça on refuse les cheveux sur wii
mais je prendrai une planète
ça c'est une supernova oh c'est beau
elle soleil qui grandit c'est 970 méga
année par seconde en année ce que ça
représente 900 soit 9 millions d'années
par seconde là ce qu'on voit au super
nova type ia olala mais ça j'adore je
suis totalement fan ça me fait penser à
barumbu les mammouths voilà en version
fluorescentes au regard des sas et 20
ports comme ça puis c'est tellement
jolie ou alors ça ce que c'est beau mais
ce que c'est beau j'ai vu sa bombe à
écouter les gens chalon laisse quitté
là-dessus écoutez j'ai bien kiffé ce jeu
là il est vraiment super alors c'est
vraiment il est tout sauf marrant mais
par contre il est je sais pas il est
beau mais la musique les images c'est
incroyable la terre est de faire de lui
depuis qu'un seul du film regardez on
est emprisonné comme ça au sein de honor
bar où il ya tout qui pète abbaoui aille
forcément sur la trajectoire
combien y en a maintenant les us that a
carrément la planète afin je suis bien
content qu'on ait qu'une seule l'udps
qui en plus se prendre des météores et
astéroïdes à notre place
oui bah ouais j'en sais y'a pas de cette
vidéo sur sur une yole hiver le cemoc
c'était c'était magnifique merci au long
de leur processus jeu parce que [ __ ]
on fait pas souvent des jeux bon comme
ça qui te captive à ce point mais quand
on en fait c'est beau la petite phrase
un peu nul de fin de vidéo réécouter gt
ça vous aura plu même si à mon avis vous
n'avez pas beaucoup rigolé on aura
découvert cette oeuvre d'art ensemble
n'essaie pas aimer f2 ou ça vous a plu
ben écoute et si je trouve d'autres jeux
comme ça qui sont d'une telle beauté est
bon on sera un plaisir d'y jouer et
découvrir tout cela ensemble je fais de
gros mission surtout très vite dans une
prochaine vidéo et moi je vais rester
là-dessus encore deux heures et demie
voilà si la vidéo sont en retard vous
savez pourquoi aller à bercy autour du
groupe peace
oh